hey everybody listen listen together run  okay I saw a monster it came to me from  out of the sky  need me to sound like  I thought a mythical creature I had only  heard exist in legend yeah I did no I  did no I saw it doesn't exist get this  ridiculous story and tell the truth I am  telling the truth we believe you Yugi  welcome to the SES stands for small food  exists sucker we have been collecting  proof of the small foots existence  behold the scroll of invisible wisdom  imagine amazing stuff they pawn here  this proves nothing I know what I saw  wait he's gone  [Music]  I should introduce myself small foot oh  that's supposed to fall out like that  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you